my name is steve ducey and i've been at  fox news coming up on 25 years when fox  news was just getting started they said  okay we've got one job left how would  you like to be the weather guy isn't  this cool i'm on tv with captain  kangaroo i just had fun with it the  bosses said just tell us how warm it's  gonna be and if it's gonna rain we  realized pretty early people liked the  news but they liked it with a little  sense of humor this is america's fastest  growing breakfast food i had no idea  that i would become one of the hosts of  the number one cable news show in the  world fox news channel is a family now  my family is actually at fox news where  my son peter is the white house  correspondent people will come up to me  and they'll go steve you and your wife  did a really good job because that kid  is a great reporter  [Music]  you